hey mata i heard you built a cool
application recently
hi martin yes my colleague guillaume and
i
built a service app it has multiple
services
communicating in a nice choreography
choreography uh can you explain that a
little
sure when you have a set of
microservices
how do you get those microservices to
interact with each other toward a common
goal
there are two approaches choreography
and orchestration
[Music]
in choreography each service works
independently
and interacts with other services in a
loosely coupled way
through events in orchestration
there is a central orchestrator
controlling all interactions between
services
in our app called pika daily we decided
to go with choreography
pic daily what does that mean good
question
it's a picture sharing app we built it
as a prototype
for a customer in london we combined
piccadilly circus
from london with picture sharing and
decided to call it pika daily
oh cool uh can i see a demo mata
of course let's take a look i already
have some pictures uploaded in the
app under each picture you can see some
labels
these are labels extracted by vision api
telling us what the picture is about
around each picture
you can also see a colored border this
is the dominant color of the picture
again extracted by the vision api
the app also creates a collage of four
most recent pictures
and you can see that under the collage
tab
oh nice app so can you tell us what's
happening behind the scenes
and how you use this choreography
pattern
let's look at the architecture diagram
first
users upload pictures to a cloud storage
bucket using an app engine front end
that triggers an event to a cloud
function
this cloud function uses vision api to
extract labels
and colors of the image and saves them
to cloud firestore
the same event triggers a cloud run
service that creates a thumbnail of the
image
there is a second cloud run service that
gets triggered by class scheduler
to create a collage of four four most
recent pictures on a schedule
finally a third cloud run service gets
triggered by deletion events
it does some cleanup after an image is
deleted
we are using built-in events for cloud
functions
and event arc for cloud run the whole
architecture is event driven
also known as choreography i see
so what are the pros and cons of
choreography
yeah in choreography services are
loosely coupled
and because they are loosely coupled
they can be changed and scaled
independently
if a service fails the rest of the
services can still send and receive
events
so there is no single point of failure
and if you want to add a new service or
remove
an existing service to a new domain
eventing makes that really easy
all right so then how do you monitor
event-driven systems like this
well with all events flying around it's
actually quite hard to monitor
event-driven systems
it's also not so easy to catch errors or
apply global error and rewrite policies
i see and where is the business logic
captured
business logic ends up being a side
effect of the architecture
it's spread out to each service and
there's no single central place that you
can point to
got it so can we fix these cons somehow
yes we can we need to keep the loose
decoupled nature of event-driven
services but also bring some structure
in the flow of events
we need some kaino and orchestrator
check out the next episode for details
cool thanks mehta and thank you everyone
for watching
if you want to build this app there's a
hands-on workshop with a series of labs
the code is open source on github as
well all the links are in the show notes
[Music]
bye